today on our show what Logan snick snick
snick snick force next we're gonna sneak
the [ __ ] review of Logan or old land
Logan yeah really it's called Logan the
motion picture me and Mark talking about
Logan
finally right now finally welcome The
Fatman I'm Batman X fans I'm Kevin Smith
I'm uh Chris Nick Darden we changed our
name for this general episode of OTV
review uh Logan came out like [ __ ]
ages ago we didn't get to talk about it
because I was off doing stuff he was off
doing stuff but here we are to talk
about indeed a lot of people on Twitter
every day like where's your walking
review here it is give me a single this
movie blew me away oh my god give us new
jobs update in this Wiz holy [ __ ] this
movie is amazing I have a long time to
think about I've only seen it once you
don't want to see it's a preview night
Thursday or whatever [ __ ] when it opened
at midnight with Adam F Goldberg dude of
the Goldbergs
and who went Matt and Andy Matt Myra
names gonna do both work on the
Goldbergs as well writers and show so I
went with geek nerd and you know I think
we had to pass around tissues at one
point not for the obvious like
tear-jerking moments just for the jerk
jerking moment this was a movie where if
he [ __ ] one and pop one person skull
he did 200 times and I was never like
that's gratuitous never got tired of
never I was like he keep doing every
time he's like just [ __ ] pop the
snick through somebody's head I was like
oh my God look at him enjoying their
r-rating I was so not tired of it I
wanted a 12 yo girl to do it to all I
was delighted when she did so much other
like user and use the one in your foot
kill them all
like God sort of Mountain oh it was
delightful from start to finish and what
nobility and
and dignity they afforded those
characters yeah throughout the
throughout that the in the end of their
lives
spoilers you've all seen Logan but if
you haven't there's gonna be like a boy
little why there look it's like there
ain't many left except Logan himself and
Professor X and it's a very bittersweet
story there very sad story but you know
you think about all the x-men stories
you've ever read movies you've seen and
like they're stories of hope and like
you know people that are marginalized
but you know come together to manifest
themselves their power what have you
they even reference it in the [ __ ]
movie with the looking at x-men comic
books and Logan being like maybe 30 this
perhaps 30% of it out and not like this
or whatever but they show you real
people who just happen to have some
abilities those movies prior to this
wasn't so much about real people
abilities is about abilities that these
people have the abilities take front
center here it's character study it's
almost an indie film I mean it very much
is and it's it's it's the sort of thing
that most superhero story telling is
second act it's it's kind of origin or
middle because ending is a thing that
it's not in the best intentions aware of
us to be here story because you have to
keep doing this it's all second act it's
all second act you're never going to
resolve it but this movie unlike almost
every other movie gets to take advantage
of 20 almost 20 years of us living with
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine now and all of
us have accumulated like story weight
and dignity and and gravitas like all of
this sort of barnacle to this movie in a
way that I've never seen before because
nobody else has had that kind of
permanence with a character before it is
I mean maybe maybe like Captain Kirk's
final voyage like you get to see William
Shatner you know second star the right
sail on till morning
because you've been with that guy as
that character for 35 except we saw we
saw his death yeah well it wasn't
now count that death [ __ ] it was a
bad
the debt and it was like you know at the
end of the day that's how one of the
greatest characters in TV history went
out as part of the Canon as part of the
record now the way they sent our boy
away so much dignity so much respect so
much love so much plausibility which is
weird because look about a guy who's
Nixon polish your [ __ ] head open with
claws but hope as well super hope at the
end it's like you know like um they
could call that Logan :
the New Mutants yep and at one point
somebody said something about me I heard
the term new music so I look like that
it was a dazzling show of cinema story
Thomson Mac story con James Mangold
reading abyss directed another Wolverine
moving ship but he goes back to be
Wolverine though Wolverine but he goes
back to was that cop movie was stallone
coupling could remember that title
wonderful flick 3:10 to Yuma remake yep
wonderful flick the most stuff he's done
wonderfully he didn't get on the line
also fini I think so
not right the Dewey Cox story there no
that's what hard he did the Joaquin
Phoenix with rich witticism thousand
thanks my good friend this is a quantum
leap forward not just for him as a
filmmaker but for the genre as a whole
because it proves that like you can tell
an adult story like Deadpool told you
prove that you can make an r-rated comic
movie do business I'll take single on
this please give the medicine Deadpool
prove you can take comic book movie I
make it are rate and do business that's
wonderful Logan proves that you can take
comic book movie and make it grown-up as
[ __ ] grown-up is [ __ ] make it a story of
I'm old middle-age I'm getting too old
for this [ __ ] they leave the weapons
Logan but made it even more [ __ ]
serious you know
humor in this but the story of a man at
the end of his life looking back
wondering if he's done enough good and
has one last chance to do something
positive to be a hero one last time
not just hide and protect somebody so my
god like quantum leap forward for the
genre for a bunch of people out there to
to shot a bunch of people out there to
be like this is comic-book movies - yeah
you know I got somebody tell me like
that's my favorite Marvel movie and I
said well I said what there's one better
I said no just technically it's not
Amaro because we've got a Marvel logo on
it but it's Fox and that's not Marvel
Studios but I said what you can say
without getting made fun of is this is
my favorite comic book movie it's that
in the case the person was like I'm
sorry I [ __ ] said anything with the
West my point man this it is fantastic I
put it there shoulder-to-shoulder with
Dark Knight The Dark Knight Rises no
Dark Knight The Dark Knight no darkness
second one in the Nolan trilogy that's
the high-water mark I put this next to
it I have a feeling if I watch it two
more times because dark night I watch
like [ __ ] fix time in the theater I
think if I watch this few more times
it might edge out a little bit cuz it's
not like and I'm not [ __ ] on I love
Batman the show's called fat not Batman
but at certain point you know the guy in
mask and a cape and you gotta let that
part of it go otherwise you're like
who's gonna do pee ain't none goofy
about that Wolverine now people could be
like come on dude he's got [ __ ] metal
claws come out of hand that's goofy
plausible what happen good happens or
[ __ ] if you leave it in a closet
just had knives and [ __ ] that looks like
you know it's not like looking at a guy
in a mask and a cape and again I love
Batman but this film just feels even
more serious more grown-up more
cinematic like you know and and you I
don't know I hate to say like you can
treat a little more seriously because
that's not what the genre is about and
it's not what movies are about supposed
to enjoy a good time but it this
transcended just like Dark Knight
transcended the genre of just like all
superhero movie this went beyond I keep
saying it's like you know remember
Marvel had their
blind lawyers look like this for
grown-ups right into like big boy books
that's what it felt like it was like wow
like they've been making Marvel movies
like you know for four years over Marvel
Studios and and foxes are making Marvel
x-men movies but this felt like a Marvel
epic felt like a Frank Miller graphic
novel compared to like you know
generally like the last x-men movie was
kind of a whatever it was but like you
know look at look at a guy in the outfit
look at all these outfits look at the
[ __ ] powers on display and nothing
about this movie selves intimidating to
me I'm not saying I could have done that
because I couldn't have but most of
those companies I look at and be like
that's complicated that seems expensive
I'd never do that
Wolverine man like I mean Logan seemed
like they pulled it off for a decent
budget never felt like it was
shortchanged or anything where you were
like oh I'm not seeing the spectacle you
know there's a guy with a robot hand
throughout most of the movie and again
my man pops his claws constantly it was
he's not land she does as well she was
[ __ ] fantastic this girl but like it
felt doable you know an event it felt
like man they did it for price 50k and
they just let him go [ __ ] crazy and
make a good ass movie nevermind like
marketing tie-ins and how many t-shirts
can we sell they're like just gonna make
[ __ ] a cool ass movie and they did they
delivered so this makes all things
possible big bargain like as you look
back on the timeline of comic-book
movies this is a moment getting moment
that's happened and everyone is now
going to follow this path the same way
everyone's like after Deadpool the like
huh who knew and Fox was the only one
ballsy enough to be like look [ __ ] it we
had success when our rated movie guess
what we're gonna make another r-rated
movie this time we're going to put one
of your favorite [ __ ] characters in
it will bring that's people over warned
about is God looking at this going like
yeah why can't we do it already Batman
movie you know or one of them why don't
we just do Dark Knight Returns
like if I'm if I had a Mikey drop it if
I was Matt Reeves like you know what
[ __ ] it we got we don't have the actor
with that permanence unless you're going
to get [ __ ]
Michael Keaton back and do Dark Knight
Returns and just we loop back into that
continuity up in wild it would be nut it
would make a billion dollars it really I
mean again like you talking about guy
just want a [ __ ] Oscar will came
close a bird man yeah you know but I get
it it looks like an old man you know an
old man not likely decrepit by me he
looks like he's got the age now to do it
yeah like this real though this with it
but if we were going to loop tough tough
you're gonna loop back I see the Keaton
are you almost feel like you want to
loop back to Clooney and give him
another shot of the title particularly
with a dark [ __ ] you know Batman with
the you know he was made to be like
here's my back credit card this is one
where it's like you know he's a broken
older version I'd be cool there'll be
cool yeah like this Logan is for me the
best live-action superhero movie I think
I've ever seen
Wow now I have I love the marble stuff
the boat ain't spray but those always
feel like you know comedies in a way
like they're they're playing for a
different thing they're playing for me
to handle fun yeah where's this I love
them there's no lovable wonder and
you're like I feel like a kid again just
felt like a nourishing grown-up Emile
just felt like a movie I'd have to drive
to New York to see when I was a teenager
yeah like and it's not that you can't
make a good popcorn movies not that you
can't make a good sort of might
superhero level order the Sun are
brilliantly super I'm happy with
guardians and that and some like they're
doing a great thing over there but this
is like coming asking do you think that
this gets like obstacle attention yes
and I'm like I think Patrick Stewart
might get a nomination the movie should
but it came out a little too early for
that kind of permanent yeah but you know
what man like in a war I just watch
teller high water which is a fun pilot
but if that moving getting out in for an
Oscar so can Logan you know yeah and
like both are pictures of the American
West Southwest whatever you know one
one's realistic and what's [ __ ] but
like I go if Logan came out in October
yeah I would say absolutely like when
did that poll come out February February
like Mad Max came out in May
a Deadpool came out in February I never
you know it did there was awards talk it
didn't pull off the Oscar thing but did
Golden Globe it so there's a chance that
people remember because I'm I mean but
then again people [ __ ] yeah it is
longshot because people memories short
and like there's so much coming yeah you
have Justice League coming of Wonder
Woman coming you have Guardian guardian
coming or three like Spider Man people
oh my god well I mean this yeah May July
uh yeah it might be tough for people to
build Logan was that this year but it
deserves it the [ __ ] movie is
dynamite man great script fantastic
Direction amazing performances let's
talk about [ __ ] yeah Hugh Jackman not
only plays old Hugh Jackman and foremost
a movie or like wow he's gotten old
until you see young you Jack business
I'd was that him it's him with some of
that like RDJ like II filter oh my god
he looks amazing yeah it looks good yeah
he looked damn good when he's fighting
himself I was like why didn't I do this
before there's a great [ __ ] idea and
[ __ ] that girl was fantastic Patrick
Stewart I think you're right he
definitely gets the nod how much of that
stuff I mean the the superhero story
works really well when allegory for
something else that's what science
fiction does incredibly well and for
professor eggs for Charles Xavier story
to be the allegory of Alfheim to be
allegory of a former Titan who lost his
capabilities to be that thing again but
had glimpses up like remembers it I
remember when I was the most powerful
being on the planet and it's slipping
away and when he loses control like all
those scenes of like the a bomb of
Professor X's brain go ahead here while
I stroke it out yeah like Logan is the
only one who could push through it and
x-23 but just like that stuff is so
evocative and it's haunting and it's
tragic yeah
very tragic specially they keep hinting
at what happened back in the etiquette
yeah in Westchester NY Chester and I
guess like they see like they kind of
talk about it by the end right like a
lot of people he had neck sewed loudly
border but I heard an original draft
that they were like thousands were
killed yeah I mean I also get the sense
at least from what you read
giving the drug to my West Chester
you're talking about the Academy you're
talking about the school like where's
Charles Xavier responsible for the death
of the x-men well that's that's where my
mind went
then that's where like I thought it was
just like we have a lot of people in I
thought it was just West Malkin Lane
which is where they may be a mansion is
its way hard just saying yeah baby but
like that's like that's what I thought
was that bid under those under his care
his charges and one she was supposed to
be teaching to navigate their way to the
world and their powers hater he killed
with his errant brain that's tragic
that's [ __ ] dark why wouldn't they
include that in a movie that was really
pretty [ __ ] door
I don't know maybe they thought it was
just one thing too many I think maybe
there wasn't I would have made it even
more metal something perfection yeah I
think if you knew what it meant it means
everything if you don't know what it
means it just doesn't mean anything
beyond like I was responsible for death
yeah people are mad at them you've got a
weaponized brain yeah I couldn't believe
they did what they did
yeah it is very well as ever if you tell
these people have seen it so far
I'm sure by now thus far they [ __ ]
kill him yeah and they kill them in a
way that's not like killing you know
[ __ ] Superman the end a Batman V
Superman where you see some dirt rides
it [ __ ] kills them yeah
thank you everybody the place where the
mutants are going turns out to be a real
place Eden Eden but the barium would
have [ __ ] cross and the chick lays
down to come an axe I [ __ ] bald I
balled in that moment I was like has
anybody ever done that before is that
ever happening comic book before man
Lisa like how perfect was it's great
there's a perfect [ __ ] moment the
father-daughter story of the you know
you're not my kid is beautiful if your
dad the whole thing [ __ ] you know you
can [ __ ] go to pieces by by the end
and the idea that you you as a father
cannot take your child all the way but
like you are the old world she's the new
world you are not permitted to enter
Heaven you know yeah Moses II didn't get
to yeah you didn't get you a promontory
of the problem you know and especially
because so much of Logan's life was
brutal and violent and awful and
horrible like he would never be granted
admission into heaven they used his name
too
the one from the comics how's it yeah
from what was the story remember they
did the big story George or yeah because
they're big words because in origin the
story that told his backstory needed
like I think that the first movie to
call him by that name I think there's
there's a bit in the [ __ ] the shitty
x-men origins Wolverine where they they
might have said it when they go back to
like the Vietnam era roots or whatever
the hell it is and they my movie been
disavowed though because Deadpool like
it don't exist anymore you know not
ready I mean I think it's beneficial
never get in there but still legit okay
it's so weird it's like hey man that's
been reckon that's not part of it call
NATO summit without a moral history
right when counting out Mussolini yeah
we could make make it happier for ya man
this was this movie was the absolute
truth and I think he kind of snuck up on
everybody I mean we all knew hey there's
an r-rated Wolverine movie coming nobody
expected it to be this [ __ ]
heartbreakingly brilliant nobody
expected Unforgiven even though kind of
what is it you know like old man Logan
was always a little bit Unforgiven the
last ride of the gunslinger and there is
a bit of lone wolf and cub to this yeah
I'm sure but it's it's so much and I'm
always a sucker for the one last job
story I'm always a sucker for T like the
the sunset of his years like let me just
wrap on these guns one last time and get
it done and I'm not going to survive
this journey but I'm gonna get it done
no reference to Jean no I don't think so
you miss it you know no I don't think so
like I've heard enough I don't think so
no reference to Scott any of them that
dick there's no I mean we had what was
his name the dude you know from the from
Ricky Gervais show know too much in
Marylebone Caliban that was kind of hot
we're gonna [ __ ] Caliban yeah but it was
just all handled so [ __ ]
realistically we were like wow this is
what like you could keep going and I saw
both of those dudes we're like the
zipper oh yeah and you know now you know
why literally but in the world of the
x-men
you could always you know hey it's
[ __ ] mm yeah they could do it
and I think they're smart to lay down I
think I saw Hugh Jackman say I would
play Wolverine again if it's a x-men
Avengers crossover movie that's which is
a nice carrot to dangle but I don't
think they made it I mean I was
surprised because they they have a bit
in x-men apocalypse where they go and
they show you Weapon X they show you
like yeah
Logan you [ __ ] helmet on yeah the
Barry windsor-smith wires a highlight I
expected I have expected them to recast
Wolverine for that like the this is the
young x-men we're doing it all new like
we're going to need a person to be
Wolverine again if it's not going to be
this guy really not yeah but now like
they're gonna make more x-men movies and
they're gonna make Wolverine in them so
now who you get to play what he thinks
oh my yeah if I'm them I wouldn't touch
Wolverine for a few years and let it age
let it like teep let that one live and
breathe that who am I talking to they're
like dude we already started yeah now
this in a world worse we rebooted
spider-man when Spiderman was give it up
trust me where we move over yeah it's a
shame and I mean I know it's like
someone else one day will wear the claws
that's who did such an amazing job hats
off to Hugh Jackman yeah like I remember
when a when walls were cast there was
there was a bit of [ __ ] Dougray Scott I
was anyway Scott I think they shot a
little bit with him and it was a really
they might have been there like ya know
that's what happened I thought it was a
schedule thing I think I think it might
have been a mixture of both you know
maybe I'm muddying it a little bit but
IB then went on to do Mission Possible
to write and then scuttled his career
just Billy remembers Mission Possible to
remember people like a John Woo one yeah
I just remember he took his face off
ninety-six man moved in and then and
then and then and then and then and then
and then
no no no no no it's not denim Dillon
Dillon enamines
it was a Kree internet chatter that like
fans were upset because he was too tall
Dougray Scott no Hugh Jackman I thought
he was tall to rest guys way taller than
[ __ ] you Jam a banquet Charlie Bob
Hoskins Bob Watson says the ideal will
bring two b-52 and Harry lot is that the
guy they originally wanted that true
fans wanted I mean nobody in their right
minds make some Bob Hoskins a superhero
but Nick it's good and [ __ ] Super
Mario Brothers is great Oh Roger Eddie
valiant yeah he's not the right children
yeah but they wanted like because the
character had always been like fire buff
yeah so somebody say Danny DeVito in
what world I'm glad it was Hugh Jackman
they did that fart justice but [ __ ]
James mangle did that character he gave
that carrot look they never robbed that
character his dignity Wolverine was
fantastic and eternal and they've done
him justice in the movies always done
but holy [ __ ] they sent him out with a
biking [ __ ] funeral ablaze yeah on a
yacht bound for [ __ ] glory and
infinite infinity like it was you
couldn't imagine a more perfect send-off
tough to imagine a more perfect
Wolverine moving there oh they never
make another one you know they're gonna
bud yeah man that one will stand the
test of time it's [ __ ] dark night
good and people will start saying things
are Logan good Logan my big new bar
could be and I do think that no matter
who plays will drain from here on out
how many people play Wolverine from here
on he will always be Wolverine to us in
the same way that Christopher Reeve is
always super meta and that like Sean
Connery was always James Bond right
Harris like oh that ain't you like
probably Dalton huh yeah - true you know
what we'll probably see like 9 mmm
I bet you will see three more Wolverines
in our lifetime wouldn't surprise that
sounds like a premonition you will see
three and then you will die wait for the
blood new burial arrived there it is you
want our Logan review here it is a
[ __ ] loved it better late than never
and it was way better surprise here's my
hot cake on
Logan it's damn good here's my hotter
cake it's really fantastic it was a
British genius flick claws-out Nick for
all week for all and vogue close-up yeah
all good and the foot claws as well
fantastic stuff and you know what shout
out the guy who is the bag out the metal
arm Oh Boyd Holbrook does name yeah he's
on narco yeah I love him on Marcos and I
loved him in this he's got this like
slinky Sinister's I'm mystified by I
loved him in a thing housing perfectly
good no no he's [ __ ] dynamite yeah
yeah this is good as a drawl too little
like it's like evil McConaughey Oh a
good get to get that guy even better
education Boyd Holbrook the evil economy
Hal Holbrook son do you think maybe you
think could be yes we research to the
internet Boyd Boyd these great narcos if
you haven't seen our goes watch that two
seasons worth of it good she'll and he's
in it he's wonderful anyway he was
tremendous in this he's really a great
foil a great bad guy yeah cuz some good
minute yeah he gives good good guy in
the show ah there it is Logan folksy a
maybe we don't know we don't know don't
look up and see if Boyd Holbrook is
related to a whole board let us know in
the comments as Marx theory very much
[ __ ] anyway that usually I like Marx
theories but Chris Pine is these are I'm
related to Will Smith wait you know that
way to do the show try to butter up the
local make at some point we would go to
West Philadelphia where you're born and
rich now I moved down here with my Logan
buggin is you can't get better than this
right now
this is as good as it [ __ ] get take
the day off go see a matinee tomorrow
just cuz yeah I might actually go back
and see it again for at least years I
should was I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
myself dude I was like I was hooting
hollering I was laughing every time he
[ __ ] pop those call this closet of
someone's cause [ __ ] you like I had such
a good time and then at the end I was
weapon it's great no all began with a
Deadpool [ __ ] treat teaser which I
was like
the movie today put Ryan Reynolds's [ __ ]
when I'm with you Weapon X I was Weapon
X good been a long time um Logan folks
you love it you love it that's for fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
come back next time we're talking about
some other [ __ ] same bat-time same
bat-channel
podcast comma work YouTube that
counselors Kevin Smith
[Music]